(man) the sharks are back.
They're looking for the best
products and Businesses
America has to offer.
And tonight, guest shark
LORI Greiner joins the tank.
I'm gonna write you
a check write now.
Hopeful entrepreneurs
come to the shark tank
seeking an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
Tell me about sales.
No sales to date.
Why should we invest in you?
Sales from a $10,000 investment
were $120,000.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest,
using their own money...
I have $400,000.
I've just put it on this table.
Let's pretend it's there.
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
If I walk, you lose the tv,
and the tv isn't easy for mark.
Actually, I own two tv networks,
so that's not the problem.
Let's talk about reality here,
Buddy.
There's absolutely nothing
proprietary about this.
You hire them and you know
what they do right after that?
They're quit 'cause
you're a son of a bitch
and they won't want
to work with you.
Oh, that's crap.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with Nothing.
You're saying,
"Hey, let's get married,"
and I'm saying... (chuckles)
"Hey, buy me a drink first."
This is a real slick Willie
over here.
It's sink...
or swim.
I gotta tell you,
you can take a lot of abuse
and still hang in there.
I like that about you.
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-made,
filthy rich Investors.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 Billion.
Lori Greiner is
the queen of qvc.
She holds 108 patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing $500 million
in Worldwide retail Sales.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-made
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas Mavericks.
First into the shark tank is
Jared Joyce, a serial inventor
Who's hoping to sell the sharks
on one of his many ideas.
This is going to be fun.
My name is Jared Joyce.
I'm an inventor/entrepreneur,
and today,
in exchange for $250,000,
I'm offering you 25% equity
in my patented
five-minute furniture.
In my hand are
assembly instructions
for one of my competitor's
furniture designs.
They are printed on several
pages, in multiple languages,
and they come with
a frustrating bag of hardware.
My furniture Designs
require none of this.
Let me show you.
This is a cube design,
and the first thing to notice
is this patented joint,
which allows us to comfortably
slide two side walls together,
to create
a flush right corner.
Notice that all side walls are
identical,
so there's no confusion
as to what part to grab
or in What order to assemble.
You simply grab and go.
Once the side walls are
connected,
we have created a perimeter
for our Backer piece
to rest on.
And finally, this is
the rotational lockdown.
This is the piece that makes
this ease of assembly
like nothing
you have ever known.
Simply drop it in,
quarter turn...
(Click)
and Boom. Can't come apart.
Wow.
Thank you.
We currently have over 30
designs using this joint system.
And this joint system can be
applied to any 4-sided object--
tables, chairs, dressers,
desks, bookshelves.
For those of you who have
ever purchased
the traditional bookshelf,
you know that if you are lucky--
if you are lucky--
it will take you
at least an hour
to put that bookshelf together.
These bookshelves assemble,
with no tools required,
in under five minutes.
So I invite you
to come up and play,
experience
this ease of assembly.
Or if you prefer, we can jump
into the always exciting q & a.
Q & A sounds good to me.
Let's do it, Kevin.
Why don't you tell me
about sales?
No sales to date.
Our second patent issued
four months ago.
We currently have two companies
interested in Licensing.
So, Jared, you put a $1 million
value on your company
by asking me to give you
$250,000 for 25%.
Correct.
Is your strategy
from day one
not to bother
trying to get distribution,
but to simply license it?
Let me give you
my thoughts on that.
I am no stranger when it comes
to getting paid to go away.
(mark and Robert laugh)
trust me, neither is Kevin,
but usually by his dates.
Licensing is
how I made my money.
You made your money?
Have you made money before?
I run a research
and development Firm.
Uh, we currently have over
80 products in the portfolio,
and this is one of them.
But the reason I don't think we
should license this technology
is that regardless
of the next dot-com BOOM
or next best-selling app,
the world will need
furniture solutions.
So, Jared,
what have you invented
in that portfolio of 80
or 90 patents, however many,
that's made any money?
Uh, only one so far is
making money.
What is that product?
I'm just curious.
That product is called
the plug hub.
How much money has it made?
Uh, it's been on the market
for a month.
I think they sold
10,000 units.
Now how much money do you have
invested in this?
Uh, in this--
w-with All my designs,
I try not to put in
more than $1,000 myself.
$1,000?
S-so with that,
there's $250,000
of investor funds in this.
So the $250,000 you spent is
purely on getting to today?
Correct.
Are you offering us equity
in your company
or in this one product?
Today I'm pitching
the five-minute Furniture.
As you can imagine, if we do
this deal and we like it,
we like each other,
of course I'd be open
to discussing more deals
in the future.
Why aren't we getting offered
anything
in the company in general?
The problem with That statement
is that you're saying,
"Hey, let's get married,"
and I'm saying... (chuckles)
"Hey. Buy me a drink first."
This is a real slick Willie
over here.
(laughs)
I got it.
You're saying that you're
putting me on an interview
when I may give you
a quarter-million dollars
for a bunch of plastic stuff,
and you may employ
a bunch of people
to go and push all your other
brands, make the contacts.
No, that's not
what you're saying.
You're saying We get
a piece of all the products.
No.
That's not what
he's saying at all, Robert.
If you're lucky enough
to invest in his one product,
you may impress him enough
to give him more money
for the rest of the crap
he has.
Exactly.
I'm out.
Jared, I-I just have to ask
because I'm curious.
$250,000 you've raised
for this patent.
How much money have you raised
across the other 79 products
that you've designed?
Uh, a total
of about $1 million.
How long ago
did you start raising money
for your first design?
Seven years ago.
How many of those investors
have you returned
all of their funds for?
So far, none.
You're serving
too many masters.
If I gave you $250,000,
you have to eat, sleep,
and breathe this one deal.
I don't see you doing that.
I think you're an inventor
extraordinaire in your own mind.
So I'm out.
Jared, let me tell you what--
what I'm struggling with here.
When I take a dollar
from an investor,
I feel a huge, a huge amount
of responsibility for that.
I want to pay them back.
I will pay them back
before I eat.
So I just don't have
the confidence
in you to deliver.
I like the product.
I just don't trust you.
I'm out.
Three sharks are out.
Lori and Kevin are Jared's
last chance to make a deal.
I understand the importance
of what you've done.
I think it's brilliant.
I really like this.
I like that you have patents.
But I don't want
all of your other stuff,
the baggage
that goes around with this.
So I'm willing
to make an offer to you
if another shark
will go in with me.
I'll put up $125,000,
but I want 100% of this.
We'll buy the patents.
We'll take over doing
the furniture ourselves.
And you go back and you do
what you were doing
with everything else
and everybody else.
But you gotta get Kevin.
I'm there.
It's a slick move, Lori.
So you're gonna buy
the whole thing,
fire him before
he even leaves out of here.
(Lori) Yep.
I like that.
(Kevin) Jared, let me tell you
why you should do this deal.
Your history so far
has been a Roach Motel.
Dollars go in.
They never come out.
After seven years,
no return of capital investors.
That's bad.
Here's an opportunity,
with Lori and I,
to have your first huge win.
You have nothing now for this.
2 minutes from now,
you have $250,000 cash.
$250,000
for 100% of the patent,
and you stay at home.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪♪
Three sharks are out,
and Jared has one offer
on the table
from Lori and Kevin--
$250,000 for 100%
of five-minute furniture.
You've told us
you've made nothing to date
on any of your ideas,
any of your patents.
This is your moment.
You can make $250,000
and know that one
of your inventions is
gonna get out there,
and you go free
to work on--I don't even know
how many others you have.
This is your pass. This is it.
You get your money back,
you take it, and you rebuild
on something else.
The ability to do that
is amazing,
and the risk is Lori's and mine.
We have to figure out
how to get our money back.
I'll make this easy
for you guys, in that
when I look
at the people that I lead,
the people that depend on me
for employment,
I could do more, be more,
lead more
if I could plug in
to your networks
and work with you.
So I am very much interested
in becoming a partner with you.
Uh, for me, I like our deal.
I say you're out.
At the end of the day,
you don't bring any value
beyond what you've done so far.
This is the honest, brutal,
hard truth,
and we should deal with that
right now.
What are we looking at
as far as licensing and your--
doesn't matter. You're
out of it. You're gone.
No, I mean, as far
as my percentage of royalties
that I would take
into the Future.
None. We get 100%.
You're done.
This deal is
we give you $250,000 cash,
and you don't have
my phone number.
So you're giving me
an opportunity to break even
but not make a profit
for my investors.
Right--right now you have
no profit, no return of capital,
no track record
of any return...
right.
And a whole bunch
of really unhappy Shareholders.
Seven years is an eternity
for an investment
that never returns anything.
You know, honestly,
I go with my gut.
I don't think you're going
to be a good businessperson
or partner for me,
and so I like the deal that
we've put on the table for you.
But if you won't take that deal,
then I'm gonna rescind it.
Again, my preference comes to
I want to be partners with you,
I want to build a business.
If you're not interested
in that--
back to your concern
of paying back investors,
I'm--I'm on that.
But with that,
I would need a royalty,
because otherwise, all I'm doing
to my investors is saying,
"Hey, it's been seven years.
We broke even."
Jared, you're not listening.
We're not interested
in partnering with you.
We want to give you
a quarter of a million dollars,
end of story.
Do you want to take it or not?
I want to hear your answer
in 15 seconds or I'll be out.
What are you gonna do, Jared?
It's now or never.
I would not be doing right
by my investors
to say that I took 7 years,
$250,000, we're breaking even,
no opportunity.
Good luck, Jared.
See you on twitter.
Good for him
for sticking to his guns.
He's a slimeball.
That guy had so many patents,
so many products.
I think he made a huge mistake.
Huge Mistake.
He did make a huge mistake.
I thought he blew
an opportunity.
Last season,
Johnson Bailey
came to the shark tank
with his product,
the man candle...
we've got pot roast,
we've got golf course,
barbecue, football,
draft beer, popcorn, or--
say there's somebody
in your house
you really don't want
to hang around too long--
We've got the fart candle.
(laughs)
But he left without a deal.
I really call it
a vitamin c deficiency,
'cause you don't have cash,
credit, or enough customers.
I'm out.
Let's see what he's up to now.
Even though I didn't get a deal
from one of the sharks,
they gave me advice and told me
exactly what I needed to do
to make my business flourish.
I secured the capital I needed
to be able
to grow my business properly,
and my business
is now exploding.
I took my sales
from over $70,000 a year
to over $250,000 a year.
I'm in over 500 retail stores
all across the country.
I'm also in some big chains
like Spencer's gifts,
Kirkland's, and Hallmark.
I really do feel
Like a c.E.O. Now.
I come every day to my Office.
I have full-time employees.
I have a national sales Force.
Can you bring over
some more lids, please?
I used to hand-pour
all of my candles at home.
Now I have full-time employees
in my manufacturing facility
helping me keep up
with the demand
of all of the orders
We're getting.
In this economy,
it feels great to be able to
hire and employ people, and also
be able to give back some.
It's exciting.
I have truly become a C.E.O.
♪♪♪
My name is Raven Thomas
and I live in Gilbert, arizona.
(groans) hold on tight.
I've been married for 11 years,
and I have 2 boys.
After I had
my second boy, Aaron,
I decided that
I really wanted to be home,
so I gave up my career
in criminal intelligence
to be the mom
that I always wanted to be.
I was really enjoying
being a stay-at-home mom
and started, um,
getting creative in the kitchen
and decided to give out
chocolate-covered pretzels
as christmas gifts,
to save a little money.
People really loved them
and they encouraged me to keep
making them and even sell them,
so I decided to go for it,
and within, like, three months,
I had massive orders
that just blew my mind.
I just didn't know
what to do with Them.
Hey. How are you?
Hey, Raven.
Good. How are you?
Got some more pretzels
for you.
Excellent.
I got so many orders,
that I could not even
stay in my kitchen anymore.
I had to go and find
a rented kitchen
and get people to help me,
but the problem was,
I didn't have money
to pay for anyone,
so my mom and my sister
came to help me.
Looks good, looks good.
I need the sharks' help
because I continue
to get a lot of orders
and there's just no way
I can keep up with them.
I need the capital
to make the product.
And I'm afraid
if I don't get the sharks' help
I won't be able
to produce the orders
and I'll just lose my business.
♪♪♪
My name is Raven Thomas
and my company
is the painted pretzel.
I'm seeking $100,000
in exchange for 25% of equity.
I started the painted pretzel
almost three and a half
years ago
after leaving
a career that I loved,
to become a stay-at-home mom.
People loved them so much,
they suggested that I sell them.
I could keep describing them,
but how about you just try them?
And I think you'll be hooked.
Oh, yeah.
Bring 'em on.
(Lori laughs)
What makes the painted pretzel
So amazing
is that our pretzels come in
unlimited flavor combinations.
We coat our pretzels
in many types of chocolates,
from white, dark, milk,
to butterscotch,
peanut butter, and mint,
and then top them
with unique toppings
like Candy bars,
nuts, and even fruit.
Oh, wow.
Mmm.
This is fantastic.
Mmm!
I'm here because I would
really like a strategic partner
and I need the investment.
We've had a great start,
but it's nowhere near
Its full potential
and I could really
use your help.
The painted pretzel is fun,
it's yummy, it's unique,
it's working,
and most importantly,
it's positioned to make
both of us some serious cash.
So who's ready?
Raven, give us
some numbers on sales.
Over the last 12 months,
we've done about $75,000.
We just got another order in
last week for $64,000.
And not only that--
I have $140,000 worth of orders
that I did not have
the capital to Fill.
Who was that with?
We have neiman Marcus,
we're in, um, Sam's club,
Stein mart, airports--
how long? For how long
have you been in those places?
This is our fourth season
in neiman Marcus.
We've sold out in some
of their stores in one day,
online in less than a week.
You said your typical order from
a large retailer is $60,000...
mm-hmm.
But your total sales last year
were $75,000.
Did I hear that correct?
You heard that correct,
but we also--
I also have a $140,000
that I was not able to fill.
Okay, Raven,
the thing that's troubling me--
and I think you're gonna
have to answer this now...
okay.
There's many,
many pretzels on the market
with chocolate on 'em.
Right.
There's nothing unique.
So the question is,
for the painted pretzel,
what's different,
what makes you any better,
and why are you gonna
be able to survive
if there's nothing unique
about what you do?
Our--our product is just--
is based on awesome ingredients
and quality of ingredients,
the style, the packaging--
makes us totally unique
to the market.
You will not find another one
even comparable to us.
What do you sell
that rou--larger round tin
to neiman Marcus for?
Um, $14.50.
$14.50, and it costs you
how much to make it?
Um, just under--
like, around $7. $7.
$7 to make.
What I'm really curious about is
you're selling it to neiman's,
but how many times a year
do they order?
Um, they order
a couple times in the fall
and then they'll
do it again in the spring.
How many stores
are they putting these in?
In every one of their stores
and Online. They're--
what flavors
are they ordering?
An assortment.
They don't decide
what's in it. I do...
got it.
And they take it
like that.
So they say,
we want a unique assortment,
because you're saying is,
Everybody else is selling
the black, the white,
the basic stuff, right...
right
and you're able to come in
and say, look,
I'm gonna have a really cool
gift that someone can give...
right.
'cause it's got Heath, coconut,
all these funky flavors.
Right.
Raven, can I see that tin?
My kids will eat anything
that you put chocolate on.
Work with me on this
for a second,
because this is
my moment with you.
I have $400,000.
I've just put it on this table.
Let's pretend it's there.
Okay.
I get this tin--
can I borrow that for a second?
I put it beside the $400,000,
and I go online and I say,
who can make me pretzels
with stuff and chocolate
and flavoring on them
that look like this?
How many people,
you think, Can do that?
I think, a lot.
Maybe, but they can't
do it like me.
Sure they can.
They can't--
(mark) no, they can't.
You know why?
Because you've put your heart,
your soul, and your love
into it, and you care
about the business.
That's just wonderful.
It's called sweat equity,
Kevin...
that's just wonderful.
And you might not like to do
work, but some people do, right?
That's just wonderful.
Cry me a river, mark.
Sweat--Sweat equity
has value.
Let's talk about
reality here, Buddy.
The reality--
there's absolutely nothing
proprietary about this at all.
And you know
what happens next, Kevin?
And it's not worth $400,000.
You know what happens next?
You hire them, and you know
what they do right after that?
They quit 'cause
you're a son of a bitch
and they won't want
to work for you.
Oh, that's crap.
She's not going anywhere.
This is her baby.
So look,
at the end of the day,
we got to deal
with reality.
If you can't tell me why I can't
hire somebody just like you
to make this
with a $400,000 pile of cash--
I bet you only have to spend
$20,000 to get this done.
Kevin, it's not
a computer business.
It doesn't matter!
There's no proprietary
software here.
If you had to say to us
right now
why we should invest in this,
give us your very best.
Why should we invest in you?
The main reason is because
I have two little kids
and I'm showing them that
you just follow your dreams,
you can do whatever you decide
to do with your life.
I'm doing it, I'm successful,
and I'm-a keep going.
It makes me happy
and it's fun.
It's, you know, it's something
that I really love to do.
That's not enough for me.
Yeah, you know what, Raven?
That's a good story,
but it's not a good reason.
Okay.
(Robert) This is
the real world of business.
Right.
When someone like that
asks you that question,
you got to give her
a benefit as investor,
so let's do that again.
Okay. Let's do it again.
Don't tell me
about your family--
well, before--before
you do that again, I'm out.
Good.
Give us one reason
that we should invest in it.
One reason is that...
and maybe you would change
your mind when I say this--
ain't gonna happen.
Okay.
Well, I had to walk away
from a $2 million deal
because I did not have
the capital to fill the Order.
Hello.
That's a good reason.
That's a good reason,
I would think.
That was better. Good job!
Shut the front door.
(laughs)
Good for you.
Wh--who was it from?
Sam's club.
You got an ORDER
from Sam's club...
yes.
And you had to
walk away from it?
For $2 million?
I had to walk away
from that because--
how long ago was that?
I just spoke to them last week,
and the door's wide open.
I could fill the same order
within the next 12 months.
Okay, Raven, I'm gonna
sell you now, right?
Do you have an interest
in being my partner?
I do. I'm here. You rock.
Okay. Well, I'm gonna make it
very, very simple for you.
I own the mavericks, right?
Yes.
We could sell those
in our Arena.
Absolutely.
Did you know that I own
landmark theatres?
Absolutely.
We can sell those
all across landmark theatres.
I'm prepared to give you
$100,000 for 25%
if you're ready
to say yes right now.
Wh--
you better say yes right now.
Yeah, you better say yes.
I'm ready to say yes right now.
Done.
Wow.
(Robert and Lori sputter)
Congratulations.
(Raven) Thank you.
There's no negotiation.
He just gave her exactly
what she was looking for.
I got one problem with these.
I will eat 'em all,
so you're not allowed
to send me any.
Eat them all.
Thank you.
Thanks, Raven.
We'll be in touch very shortly.
(Lori and mark) Good Luck.
Thank you very much.
Yes!
I'm so excited
that the painted Pretzel's
gonna be at the maverick games
and landmark theatres.
It's like a dream come True.
(squeals)
I just love mark Cuban's
business savvy,
but his personality
is just adorable,
so I'm so excited
to work with him.
♪♪♪
Next into the shark tank
is Ryan Naylor,
who believes he has
a fashionable accessory
with health benefits.
My name is Ryan Naylor,
and I'm the founder
of esso watches.
Esso watches
is a silicon watch company
focused on fashionable designs
infused with
Negative ion technology.
We're seeking
an investment of $35,000
in exchange
for 20% of the company.
Every day, our bodies
are bombarded by positive ions,
which are molecules
that are simply emitted
from Electronic devices--
computers, tvs,
fluorescent lighting.
Too much positive ion
on our bodies
puts unnatural pressure on us.
What we have done is, we use
the counterpart of positive ion
to help bring our body back
to its more natural state,
Called negative ion.
What we do is,
we put it in our watches,
and it helps restore
our energy field in our bodies.
Just want to make sure what
you're telling me here, Ryan.
You're basically saying
this positive-negative Ion thing
is a real health concern.
'cause it sounds a little,
you know...
fluffy?
Well, it sounds a lot
like a coffee enema.
Supposedly good for you,
but who knows, right?
Right.
You might be a little skeptical
if it indeed works,
so I'd like to do
a quick balance test
to see if you can
feel the difference.
So anybody want to try?
All right.
(mark) go for it, Lori.
(Ryan) This is gonna
test your balance,
so what I want you to do is,
put both arms out like a "T,"
and then just resist my pressure
So let me put a little pressure.
So now just stand on your
left foot. Are you balanced?
(laughs) No.
(mark) That's good!
(Robert)
she can't even do that!
This is a good challenge because
I can't even stand. Right.
Now just put on--put on a watch.
Got a pink one just for you.
Now if it works,
then we know it works.
Okay.
A pink one.
Mm-hmm.
Just resist.
Resist.
Looks like it's working,
doesn't it?
Yeah, you look like you have
more balance in that one.
That's a little weird.
Yeah. Do you feel it?
Little difference?
Well, yeah.
So I actually have a few watches
for each of you guys to have.
Thank you very much.
Here you go.
Here's yours.
No, Thanks. Go ahead.
You keep it.
It's Dallas Mavericks blue
just for you.
That's okay.
You keep it.
Okay.
Thank you.
Mark, are you allergic to
positive-negative ion stuff?
No, I'm allergic to scams.
Seriously. This is not new.
It's been disproven.
What you saw
is the placebo effect.
There's athletes that wear it.
It's a joke. It's a scam.
It's not real. I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
What do you really think,
mark?
I think it's a joke,
it's a scam, and I'm still out.
Well, what I want to know--
are you selling any of these?
Sales from a $10,000 investment
were $120,000 in just 12 months.
Okay, so some people
are buying them.
That's--have you made
any money on the $110,000?
I have. We have about
$70,000 in Profit.
Really?
Do you pay
to acquire your customers?
How are you getting them?
No, my background is in
search engine optimization,
so we are the top of
all the organic search results.
I like that.
We--we don't spend
anything in marketing
other than my time that
I dedicate with my background.
So you're basically getting
your customers for free.
Correct.
How do you get the negative ions
in this rubber band?
When We're melting the silicone
into the molds,
we put the negative ion chemical
into the silicone.
With a wand?
(laughs)
You're saying they constantly
emit out of here.
How do you know
when they run out?
I mean--
it--has a net charge.
Do you have
laboratory testing on this?
Independent Laboratory testing
that shows that it really works?
Hell, No. Hell, No.
Laboratory testing?
Yeah.
That's what he needs to have.
Okay.
I mean, to be able
to sell something like this
on any tv medium whatsoever,
you have to have
independent laboratory testing
that shows your claims.
Otherwise, the f.T.C.'s
gonna be all over you.
No, we don't have anything.
It's a common thing--for
positive ions and negative ions.
We're just neutralizing
the effects
of the positive ions.
It's been around for years.
I've got to say, I think
this is a liability nightmare.
You don't have any claims that
you can back up, so I'm out.
And so you created this watch?
This design--I didn't
originate the design.
My other two designs
are my own original design.
So you're saying that
you already purchased
the first watch That's shown,
but you designed
the other two?
Yep.
I helped take a company
called rumbatime,
and they have
the exact same line,
so you're lying.
And with that, I'm out.
Are you lying?
No. W-which design?
Which are you referring to?
All three.
No, those are--
the bottom two are unique to me.
I designed those.
The other one is a--
I'll ship you a box.
Well, more than one person
can make a watch like that.
I mean, a lot of people make
the same design all the time.
I feel one
with the ion right now.
(laughs)
I'm just trying to figure out
if I can make any money
on this deal.
Kevin, I'm gonna warn you.
If you even try to make money
from this, I will come over
and just beat the living crap
out of you. It's horrible.
(laughs)
Well, Ryan, Everybody's
calling you a scam artist,
one guy called you a liar,
and you're just kind of
sucking it all in.
He's wearing his watches.
Yeah. I-I've got my balance.
I'm not... emotional.
(sharks laugh)
I got to tell you,
you can take a lot of abuse
and still hang in there.
I like that about you.
Look, Ryan, I don't believe
in any of this. I'm out.
Thank you.
There's been a lot
of interesting discussion
about scam here today.
Now how about this?
If you admit it's a scam,
maybe I'll invest.
Is it a scam?
I d--I don't believe it is.
Okay, so my options are,
I invest and have the crap
beaten out of me by mark cuban.
I don't like that too much.
You're telling me it's real,
but can't get it on tv
because it's not accredited
by anybody
in the medical profession.
I don't see an OPTION here
except to say I'm out.
Okay. Thank you for your time.
I appreciate it.
(Lori) Good luck.
Bad Luck.
Mojo.
(Robert) You know what?
I don't care what you think,
but you got to believe
in your business.
Why didn't the guy
defend himself?
That was the turning point
for me.
We beat him up pretty Badly.
Yeah, and he's not
a fighter, either.
What is he, a lover, Lori?
(laughs)
He's a lover, not a fighter.
It frustrates me that--
that mark cuban clouded
the water for the other sharks.
It's too bad that
they weren't able to--
to focus on me and my product
rather than Being
scared off by mark Cuban.
♪♪♪
Next into the shark tank
is Rick Hopper,
who's hoping
to attract the sharks
(grunts)
Oh, no.
I'm good.
I'm good. (sighs)
Bad theater.
(laughs)
Hello, Lori, gentlemen.
My name is Rick Hopper,
and my business is readerest.
I'm seeking $150,000 in exchange
for 15% of my company.
I hate losing my glasses.
Like many people, I'll spend
up to $500 on quality eyewear,
and the wasted time
and high cost
of Eyewear replacement
is terrible.
I've talked to 1,000 people
who share
the same exact frustrations
with losing, dropping,
and scratching their glasses.
The most common
solution people use
are these granny chains
and ropes
that hang around our neck.
They're annoying
and they look goofy,
and nobody wants to be
a goofball or a granny.
Another option--we hang
our glasses in our shirt,
stretching out our collars.
The next thing you know,
your glasses are in the toilet!
Have you ever had to fish
anything out of the toilet?
I have,
and it's not pretty, bro.
But now there's hope.
I call it readerest.
Here's how it works.
Take the stainless steel
back plate embedded with Magnets
hidden under your clothes.
Stainless steel front clip
easily self-centers
onto the back plate.
You simply hang your reading
glasses or your sunglasses.
Bam. Check it out.
I can jump around,
swing a golf club,
bend over all I want,
and they're not going anywhere.
Matter of fact,
I can take a major tumble,
and there they are,
safe and sound as usual,
right where I left 'em
and always within Arm's reach.
I brought samples so you can
feel the power of readerest.
Got a special one for you.
Oh, thank you--
ohh, mine has diamond.
(Robert) Thanks.
(Robert) Real diamonds?
(Lori) Well, you know...
(Robert)
It's a strong magnet, Rick.
(Lori) Yeah.
So Rick, uh, $160,000
is what you said, for 15%?
$150,000 for 15%.
So Rick, honey,
sweetie, poopsie,
you must have a lot of sales.
(sighs) Well...
actually, uh, I started
doing sales in the beginning.
I was able to generate $65,000
in sales in a market test mode,
but here's what happened.
Because I was burning
through inventory so fast,
I had to go back
into production mode
for the last couple of months.
Do you make these yourself?
Yes.
Actually, I, uh, have personally
hand-glued over 100,000 magnets.
Come on. You--really?
(Lori) You're kidding.
This is not made
in a factory anywhere?
No. No. Actually, I have
a little, uh, little, uh, shop.
How much do you sell this for?
Uh, they retail
for between $9.99 and $19.99.
For one set?
Wow.
That's a lot of Money.
Uh, Yes. Actually,
neodymium magnets aren't cheap.
Uh, it's a high-quality
Stainless steel...
right.
And there's
labor involved,
and you guys know how much
packaging costs, so--
well, how much
does it cost you to make one?
It costs me a buck and a Nickel
for the basic ones
and around $2
for the--the one--
with the most of
the swarovski crystals on 'em.
How did you come up
with this?
Well, what I did was,
I started bending paper clips
into different shapes.
I have a--one of my originals
right here, one of my favorites.
Paper Clips bent
into different shapes,
and, uh,
epoxied 'em to magnets,
put a piece of metal
under my shirt,
and I was in business.
And shazam--
old Jed's a millionaire.
Nine months later,
I realize I got pestered
every day by several people,
"How are your glasses
staying on your shirt?"
and by the time I explain it to
'em, they're like, "Oh, my gosh.
Where do I get one of those? I
can't keep track of my glasses."
Is there a patent on this?
Yes, sir.
I have a, uh, utility patent
and a registered trademark
on readerest.
I-I bought the patent
from the original Owner.
B-but What did your--you know--
I thought you said
you invented it.
I thought--Yeah.
(daymond) huh?
I did. I did. Let me explain.
I designed the product.
I went--I started getting
a lot of interest,
so I went to do
a patent search...
okay.
And was extremely disappointed
to find the patent--
it was already done.
Did a little research...
so you own the patent?
(daymond) So you got it?
So you bought it?
You bought the Pat--
I went and secured the patent.
I own the patent.
This is all happening
so fast--
what did you pay for it?
$5,000.
Ohh.
You found the guy who invented
it. You paid him $5,000.
Yes.
And you own it free and clear?
Free and clear.
So Rick, Rick.
I would say to you,
I acquired a patent for $5,000,
but I'm gonna value my company
to you at a million dollars.
You see anything wrong
with that?
Yes, absolutely.
You know, no investor
likes to speculate
and take risks at that level,
and I completely
understand that,
and my argument to that
would be,
in a very short period of time,
with very little effort,
I generated $65,000 in sales.
The potential--
when I'm in 5,000 stores,
it equates to $6 million a year
in gross profits,
and one of the reasons I'm here,
it's a strategic partner,
and I'm willing to give
more percentage of my company.
Oh, that's right. I forgot.
We have to give you the $150,000
and then we have to work, too.
(laughs)
No. No, you don't.
Actually, I actually--
with your connections--
information is the most valuable
commodity in the world.
So now you want us
to give you the money,
work, and then pass off
our connections.
Yes. Actually, n--
and I am out.
Here's the thing.
I have a question.
You're not a salesperson.
Would you say that's
not really your strength?
I'm--I wouldn't consider mys--
I'm a--I-I create things.
I've been designing little
things since I was 13 years old.
So you're an inventor,
but maybe not a good marketer?
True.
Good salesperson?
So you really need somebody
who will come in
and take over
and make this work for you.
Exactly.
Okay. I'm--I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I'm gonna make you
an offer for...
$150,000,
but I need 65% of the company.
(sighs)
and I'll get this on tv
and I'll blow out--
I'll make you a millionaire.
'cause I--
the minute you walked in here,
I knew that this was a Winner.
I think it's a great product...
thank you.
And I want to help you
to make this a huge success,
but I think you need
someone like me.
This sitting on a store shelf--
it's just gonna sit and die.
You need somebody Who's
going to show this all the time,
and tv's the perfect medium
to show this.
The product demonstrated--
it brings it to life.
You're right, the product
sitting on a shelf like that,
it's--retail would be--
I believe retail will be
a difficult avenue
for this product.
However...
um... the P--
well, I have the background
in which to get this
to infomercial and on tv,
so are you in or are you out?
Is that my only offer?
(chuckles)
Are you in or are you out?
I'd like to counter.
What are you countering?
I'd like to consider...
I would like you
to consider, um,
49% of the company.
No.
I'm a little--
I'm a little gun-shy
in Giving up total controlling
interest of the company
without a complete buyout option
with Royalties.
All of a sudden you got smart.
Oh, he just became
a businessman.
Whoa. How'd that happen?
I think he was
always a businessman.
Well, I-I did design some--
you seemed a little scattered,
my friend,
and all of a sudden,
when money comes to the table,
you get crystal Clear.
Look, Rick, now that we're
talking about real money,
let me tell you where I stand.
At best, I saw this
as a knickknack
that was sold at gas stations
and places like that.
I'm not seeing the value
that Lori is.
I'm out.
Okay, Robert.
I look at it and say,
a $1 million valuation
for a little piece of metal
with two magnets on it?
That's sheer insanity.
I'm out.
Mark, what are you doing?
I'm processing.
While he's processing,
I want you to give me an answer.
Are you shutting out cuban?
Before he speaks again.
Wow.
I need an in or out.
This is brutal.
Lori, can I please have
just one second here?
'cause I would love
to do business with you,
but this company is gonna
make a lot of Money.
Well, here's the thing. I'm
gonna make you a lot of money.
Let me help you. Let--let me
help you. Let me help you.
Wait, mark, wait.
I'm gonna make you
a lot of money.
I'm gonna get this on tv.
You know I have the audience.
You know I have
millions of viewers
that already watch my show
on qvc.
Rick, baby,
is this not your moment?
I know. I know.
So they love everything
that I bring them.
This is my one big chance.
I love this...
This is perfect for--
but--
wait, Rick. Feel the Karma.
Feel the Karma.
What a moment.
What a moment--
take it, grab it,
'cause I could walk.
Can I please hear
What mark has to say?
(Kevin) ooh!
You know what?
(Robert) Wow.
If I walk, you lose the tv,
and the tv isn't easy for mark.
Actually, I own two tv networks,
so that's not the problem.
Yeah, but they're not--they're
not home shopping Networks.
Remember that.
But I'm--I'm gonna help you,
Rick, 'cause I like you.
♪♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Rick has an offer from Lori
of $150,000
for 65% of his company,
but he first wants to hear
What mark has to say.
I'm--I'm gonna help you, Rick,
'cause I like you.
There are better options,
and for that reason, I'm out.
Ooh, and then there was one.
Yes.
And there was one.
So it was $150,000
for 65% of the company.
Would you consider...
that's--
take it
or leave it.
Is that your
flat dead only offer?
It's my flat dead,
but you're gonna be happy.
(sighs)
Rick, baby. What do you do?
You know, 35%...
of a watermelon.
Of $10 million
is very exciting to me.
And it beats gluing them
in your garage.
You're not gonna
have to do anything
but sit back
and watch the money roll in.
Lori, you got a deal.
I'd love to do this.
Great.
Wow.
Congrats, Lori.
Congrats.
Thanks. Great Idea.
Thank you.
(kisses)
Very cool, Rick.
Thank you, guys.
It's been a--been a blast.
(mark) Congrats.
Piece of metal with Two magnets
just got $150,000.
Congratulations.
What are you gonna do?
(Lori)
That's America for you.
(Robert)
That is America for you.
That's America.
Just watched a guy
go from zero to a millionaire
in the shark tank.
(sighs)
(Lori) Right.
(mark) Congrats.
Let's rock, Lori.
We're gonna rock.
Thanks, guys.
Wow.
Look at that.
Whoo-hoo!
This guy took $5,000
and made it a million-dollar
idea in less than six months.
Have you ever done anything
with eyeglasses?
Actually, I've sold
over $20 million worth
of reading glasses.
So you can
just bundle this...
so I can just bundle this
with some readers.
As soon as he walked in here,
you knew that. We had no chance.
(laughs)
Mark, can we switch seats?
35% of my company is--is not
what I wanted to be left with,
but when Lori looked
right into my eyes
and said, "I'm gonna
make you a millionaire,"
I believed her.